- [Narrator] Sour, salty, crunchy.
I think it's safe to say that
everybody loves a good pickle.
There's a little shop
just outside of Philly
that takes pickles to a whole new level.
- Welcome to Elsie's,
the sandwich shop that uses
pickles instead of bread.
Wanna try one, or two, or three?
(playful music)
(cheerful music)
My name is Katherine Cohen,
and I am the head pickle proprietor
at Elsie's in Haddon Township, New Jersey.
Elsie's was born out of necessity.
Our mom is a cancer survivor
and was diagnosed with diabetes
and that was something that
she was really struggling with.
We decided, as a family,
to start making our mom
sandwiches on pickles,
rather than on bread.
We resurrected an old family recipe
that hadn't been used
in probably a decade,
and we started from there.
Part of the process
of making our Elsie's signature pickles
involved icing down the Kirby cucumbers,
adding sea salt, vinegar, onions, garlic,
and that's all I can tell you
because my mom will not be happy
if I reveal what the recipe actually is.
- Napkin's in the bag.
You're all set, thank you.
- [Katherine] Part of
the concept with Elsie's
was to create a sanctuary
for people that have dietary restrictions:
diabetes, celiac, keto, gluten-free.
We found that there was a
need for a bread-alternative
and the pickle sandwich
became very, very popular.
One of our best-selling sandwiches
is the Elsie's famous Italian,
which is ham, capocollo,
salami, provolone,
lettuce, tomato, onion.
You can even get it
topped with Sriracha mayo,
hots, crushed potato chips.
To bite into an Elsie's
signature pickle sandwich,
it really is heaven.
It's crisp.
It's crunchy.
It really is a fantastic experience.
- Oh, yeah.
- It's unlike anything
I've ever had before.
- Very good.
- Our other option is a cucumber roll-up,
and you can have the cucumber roll-ups
made with any sandwich topping you'd like.
Both pickle and cucumber roll-ups
are served with a pair of chopsticks,
so it's really a lot of fun to eat.
We offer complimentary pickle brine.
While you're at the shop,
you're welcome to as
many pickle juice shots
as you can handle.
People take a pickle
pilgrimage to come here.
They have rerouted flights.
They have driven from Toronto, Canada,
to experience Elsie's.
It makes me feel awesome
because, at the core,
I'm really an old lady,
and I just really love to feed people.
(laughing)